30 minute workouts 20 minute recipes 10
minute mindfulness ready to become get
feel on the App Store or Google Play
hi guys it's Joanna here welcome back to
another workout session today's workout
will be focusing on your lower body we
want to work on adding more strength and
endurance to your legs but and also
thighs so this workout is low-impact so
we will not be jumping around okay but
at the same time it will be high
intensity so we want to move from one
exercise to the next exercise with very
little rest in between grab a water
bottle grab a towel and let's do this 30
minutes workout together let's start
with a quick warmup okay so easy hip
rotation just to loosen up your hip
joints and really to prep the muscles in
our legs all right so rotate to your
left big rotation all right good give me
four more on this side and we want to
change the other side all right change
hip rotation good big circles very nice
that would be
lots of squats and also lunges in this
workout you're gonna love it
few more last one and good okay now
let's just start the warm-up with a
little bit of squats okay again toes
pointed forward step shoot it with a pod
and push your butt back okay nice and
easy just go as low as you can and
remember to always keep your chest up
good few more squat low
last one more and dude okay let's work
on a little bit of stretches for your
hip flexor okay so what are we to do is
get into a plank position
step forward open up to the side place
it down step change side stretch it up
back down out up reach as high as you
can feel the stretch on your back as
well okay if you can't step so far
forward then that's fine
just go as far as you can give me one
more on each side left right and now
slowly inch yourself back up okay very
good
so each workout will be for 40 seconds
long with 20 seconds to rest in between
okay so what are we to do now is just
give me few more leg curls and we were
to get straight in to the first workout
which will be in and out squat palaces
all right last two more one more and the
first workout will be an in-and-out
squat pulse double pulse so it's gonna
be one two step out one two in one two
okay so try to stay alone if you can't
step up down pulse up and pass good so
working on your thighs and the outer
part of your glutes in really push it
back out and in good always remember to
keep your toes pointed forward keep
going
challenge yourself just stay low stay
low out very nice
so we're starting off really gentle just
to warm up the legs all right now
forward and back to lunch okay so let's
work on one leg at a time let's start
with your left leg so step right in the
middle okay what I'm going to do is
brace your core take a white step
forward into a lunge
tap back in the middle and take a step
back all right let's do this together
step forward tap step back if you want
to you can place your hands on your
waist remember as you lunge try to go as
slow as you can and keep your knees bent
90 degrees okay white step forward white
step back find your balance
look straight ahead find one focal point
good keep going
step back forward so you ship to the
burn on your right legs and your glutes
as well nice and good job change side
okay so now we're working on moving the
right leg and you should feel the burn
on your left
slice so brace your core look straight
ahead
remember we're taking a wide step
forward okay trust yourself and really
embrace your car let's go right step
forward tap tap okay so tapping in the
middle will help you to reset your stunt
white step tap and back don't rush
through this workout all right really
feel the engagement on your legs feel
the burn wide step and remember to keep
your body upright so do not punch on
lean forward if you're doing this this
is wrong
step white tap last one more let's go
one forward and rest it okay still
working on our legs it's going to be a
step and a reach okay we're going to add
in
this bit of cardio just to add that
afterburn alright so what I want to do
is take a slight step forward reach up
with your left leg step back reach and
tap ok so stay low keep your right knee
bent stay low reach and that good so the
burn should be on your right leg keeping
it bent keeping that low squat position
reach and reach give it job ha see that
burn on your glutes that's what we want
reach up ok stretch it out last five
more seconds tap and tap
give me two more one two shake it off ok
we have two likes ok so now we're
working on the other side so ready shake
your thighs padded kippis some maximych
okay all right now right leg back ready
take a step back
reach up I want to really keep your left
knee bent and tap good feel your heart
rate increasing tap reach and tap
imagine you're pulling something
- what's your chance ok reach and tap
and tap keep going
pace your breathing breathe in and
breathe out
good you're almost there
you have 10 seconds left ha see the burn
and that's what we want keep going last
three more two one ah ok as you might
notice we're focusing on one leg at a
time because by doing that you will feel
that you're working on both muscles and
if you do experience muscle imbalance
this is a good way
all right so the next workout is going
to be a reverse lunge with the kickbacks
so step back
come up lift it up step up again working
on one leg it's gonna require more
balance on your side so don't rush
through the workout find that balance
lunch down lift it up feel your butt
especially under your glutes squeeze it
hold it for one count come back up
up squeeze it and up good whoa nice last
one more good okay change side okay
working on your right side so reverse
lunge with a leg leaf are we ready if
you need to grab some water go ahead and
do it okay if you need to pause this
video go ahead and do it but let's join
me back in this workout and finish it
let's go lunge you back up back and up
so it's working on strengthening your
legs and also your core because by
having a strong core you will have
better balance
keep going tap down squeeze good up and
down nice last few more stay with me
last one more love my Belen just right
there okay if you haven't met grab it if
not you can just do this workout on the
floor okay so what a way to do is get
into all fours okay it's going to be a
good kick back with a side crunch so
watch me alright so it's gonna be a kick
back to the side back into a crunch back
right back
crunch remember tighten your core and
making sure that you're staying on all
poles and you're not tilting your hips
up side up crunch good up side up crunch
this 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 and remember to
just gaze onto the floor crunch it feel
your obliques up and crunch good change
the other side all right ok now let's
work on the other leg again on all fours
do not arch or do not hunched keep a
flat back ready let's go up sides up
crunch kick it back to the side back and
crunch it try to get your knee to reach
your elbow good up side up
crunch keep going side crunch point your
toes
to the side view the work on all angles
off your hips and your glutes keep going
a few more crunch it kick it back side
back and crunch oh very good job okay we
have three more exercises and you would
get a one-minute break all right now sit
on the floor this is gonna be a single
lick breech okay so cross your right leg
over your left leg
what I want to do is lift yourself off
squeeze feel the work on your left
bluets
down up as high as you can with a flat
back chest towards the ceiling and if
you are shaking that's good that's fine
squeeze working on your left but keep
going push it up oh my whole body is
working together up last two more up one
more up down and just rest okay change
side all right so left leg across now
we're working on your right glute okay
so try to really have a firm hook and
point your fingers forward all right
let's do this
feet planted on the ground push it up
bring it down up and down okay
get into a bridge post up very good
breathe out as you come up
okay drop it back down do not rest lift
it off back down up and down
remember to push with your heels push it
up good now a few more and down okay
where you going to end with a cardio
blast staircase so get back up we're
going to shuffle to the right touch the
floor and shuffle to the left and I want
you to stay low stay in a low squat
throughout all right ready let's go
double step tap
double step and tap and the reason why I
want you to tap the floor is to make
sure that you're going low okay so tap
remember squat low tap keep your feet
light and very good twenty seconds and
you will get a short one-minute break
right after this
you deserve it so let's keep going ten
more seconds tap plus one more on each
side
tap give me one more tap and ah okay ah
that was the end of the first round take
a short break
drink some water keep yourself hydrated
and we want to repeat the entire circuit
once more
[Music]
[Music]
okay you have about 20 seconds left and
it's going to be a total of 12 minutes
all right you know all the exercises so
I want you to really give me your best
effort if you can squat lower lunch
lower and really feel the burn on your
thighs your butt and just your lower
body and remember to engage your core
let's start in and out squat pulses okay
so in stay low out stay low for the
second round challenge yourself just
stay low and pulse this is a love-hate
relationship
okay stay low do you not come up right
now guys it's only 40 seconds you got
this you are strong so let's keep going
chest up look straight ahead look at me
stay with me I can see you sweating
I can feel a burn we're in this together
pulse that's one more let's go and one
more on the right side good back up all
right
forward and back lunch okay
so step right in the middle have more
confidence in your staff itself and take
a wide step forward all right let's
ready let's get ready
and hence up let's go take a wide step
forward you go to challenge yourself
step back immediately remove the step in
the middle this is gonna add more
challenge it's going to work on more
balance as well so white step forward
white step back good there you go you
got this
keep going if at all you feel like oh my
god I'm losing balance and then take a
step back reset step forward
reset step back and reset okay go at
your own pace and keep progressing very
good okay now let's go outside
haha step right in the middle we're
going with our right leg forward and
right leg back okay so it's going to
really work on your left legs okay let's
go ready let's go do this together
white step white step back challenge
yourself and back good and back nice
remember don't rush through the workout
okay and back go low lunge low get your
knees close to the floor and back keep
going forward and back and remember if
you need to reset just take a step in
the middle step back middle and forward
okay keep going
that's one more back and AH all right
okay a little bit of cardio so it's
going to be a step and hey rich let's
give our right leg hush our left like a
shell break let's work on our right side
so take your left leg back okay
left leg back bend your right knee reach
up and pull it in step it off as fast as
you can okay
step and reach as fast as you can
this is a short cardio workout it is
low-impact yet it's high-intensity keep
going rich rich very good halfway there
keep going
keep it right knee bend and just breathe
in and out nice that's five seconds
tap-tap-tap
and one more ah shake it out okay time
for a short break for our right leg
let's work on our left leg all right
take a deep breath okay
you deserve this shot ten seconds break
okay so right leg back let's get into
position reach your hand up alright
ready let's go tap and tap reach go low
okay really work on the single leg reach
and tap find your balance if you need to
just focus on one point I'm with you
okay
my heart rate is going crazy burning
calories and that's what we want we want
the afterburn keep going left ten
seconds reach reach as far as you can
keep your elbows keep a hand straight
keep reaching one more ah
and come back up alright okay
short break for our left leg okay it's
gonna be a lunch with a kick back okay
get into a reverse lunge whoa
I need to breathe alright my lips are on
fire let's go step back up and squeeze
squeeze
good nice one count up squeeze there you
go squeeze very good firmly plant your
right foot into the ground
take this time to bring your heart rate
down and breathe out without as you come
up
okay keep going lunch
kick back squeeze your glutes the under
but one more and good check it out okay
the opposite side all right Oh who's
sweating if you're sweating if you're
like me let me know in the comments
below
oh I am always sweaty right at the end
of my workout okay let's do this
together right leg back squeeze good
breathe out nice lift it off then find
the balance and up good
good okay go as low as you can you can't
go too low that's fine
just remove the lunch and just do the
kickbacks okay if you can't do the lunch
just step kick back step and kick back
all right
if not let's do the full exercise kick
back up kick and kick
okay all right we're getting down onto
the floor your favorite move it's going
to be a glute kickback with a slight
crunch okay so remember flat back all
right and remember to point your toes
kick it up open to the side keep a
straight line back and crunch four
counts one two three four as you open to
the side avoid from moving your hips too
much up right back and crunch take it
slow I want you to really feel the
squeeze and the contraction on your butt
up and crunch good up slide up and
crunch there you go that's two more okay
give me one more up open to the side up
and crunch good change the other side Oh
ripping okay again set yourself spread
your fingers for a firmer foundation
okay all right let's go kick your right
leg up squeeze the gluts out to the side
up again squeeze it and crunch it in up
right squeeze crunch good there you go
one two three and four kick right kick
and crunch very good site up and crunch
keep going
up crunch give me three more up crunch
up and crunchy let's do one more
together to the side to the top and
crunch okay all right
guess what three more minutes sit on
your butt take a short break
it's going to be single leg glute bridge
okay
so cross your right leg over your left
place your feet place your left feet
from you on the ground and launch okay
lift your hips up and just look up chest
point it to the ceiling
push it up feel the squeeze on your left
butt okay tighten your core squeeze good
I am shaking but I know this is working
keep going almost there
down and up okay really try your best to
push all the way up down and up alright
Oh shake it a little bit let's change
side left leg across your right thigh
and again place your hands firmly on the
ground okay so don't let your right foot
it go too far forward have it firmly on
the ground and let's go up back it down
lift it up slowly lower your butt down
and up good don't rest okay keep going
squeeze it's really important that you
hold the pose for one count right at the
top and feel the squeeze on your right
butt squeeze it up good keep going up
back down up
few more you're almost there okay give
me two more last one more up back down
and get back up time to get back up one
last 40 seconds it's going to be a side
to side shuffle with a touch down okay
tap the floor stay low stay with me your
last 40 seconds quite low let's go slide
tap stay low and tap very good okay so I
went to stay low keep going tap and
again stay light on your feet breathe
nice halfway there twenty more seconds
this is your final round and you're
getting a very deserving cooldown tap
one more let's go one more on each side
last one oh come back out okay all right
just stand up okay wiper set if you need
to do not see right now I want you to
just really take a deep breath in bring
your heart rate back down and just
breathe okay if you need to shake your
thighs just shake it out okay just left
and right shake it off all right let's
do a quick cool down all right so what
are we to do is just point your right
toes to the side and just try to reach
if you want to take a wider step just
try to reach and feel the stretch on
your hamstrings okay if you can't reach
for your toes then just hold onto your
calf very good and just feel the stretch
on your right hamstring
okay just hold for five more counts and
bring your heart rate down okay good
now change side right toes pointed
forward left toes point it out and reach
good
we've worked on our legs for the past 25
minutes so take this time to just
lengthen the muscles and just stretch it
out all right both toes pointed forward
this is one of my favorite hamstring
stretches just grab your arms link them
together lower your body down keep your
leg straight and just swing to the left
and to the right I love this stretch I
can really feel the stretch on my ten
strings and just really let your weight
carry you from left to right okay don't
fight against it just release all the
tension and drop yourself alright okay
do you most stretches okay what are we
to do is get down onto the floor right
leg forward left leg back and I want you
to just reach your arms up and lean your
body forward okay so you should feel the
stretch on your left hip flexor so just
really lean forward and now just drop
your head and twist to the side hold it
and change step back take a wide step
forward the other side drop reach up
okay so you should feel the stretch on
your right hip flexor
and now twist and just look as far back
as you can
okay and one more stretch okay if you
can't balance yourself all I want to do
is just grab hold of your left foot and
just feel the stretch on your quads all
right if not just support yourself
against a wall okay good
we've worked on a lot of balancing so
this might be a little bit of challenge
right at the end drop it okay right leg
up if you need to just lift your left
hand out stretch remember to point your
knees down okay so you should not go
forward or go too far back put it down
and just balance yourself very good and
now just drop it three deep breaths
together let's just release all the
stress all the bad energy and let's
start or end our day with positive
energy okay let's go deep breath breathe
in two more breathe in and the last one
I want you to go really loud loud side
ready let's go breathe in
pull it haha okay very very very well
done amazing job guys that is the end of
your 30-minute lower body focus do this
workout consistently to increase the
strength and endurance of your legs
thighs and also but if you enjoyed this
workout be sure to check out my own
fitness app called view which is
available on the App Store and Google
Play there are hundreds of hit workouts
yoga Pilates kickboxing and strength
training and all the workouts are taught
by internationally certified trainers so
you're in safe hands and you will see
results okay so be sure to subscribe to
my youtube channel give this video a
thumbs up share it on and I will see you
next time all the best and stay safe